last week the St Louis archbishops did
something they have never accomplished
before they made it to the semifinal
round of the US chess League playoffs
yaser San kept everyone up to date at
the club with live commentary and before
yaser even knew the result of the game
Spencer fold the archbishop's board four
player was in the basement ready to do
his postgame interview unfortunately for
Spencer he had lost the game to The
Knockouts Ethan kleene luckily for the
archbishops however everything else went
swimmingly on Board number one Wesley so
defeated Alex stunky who himself is no
stranger to St Louis championship play
Grant Master Wesley so was not anywhere
to be seen in the room that's because he
was playing on location up in Minnesota
and on Board number two Grandmaster
laang leim took Grandmaster Joel
Benjamin to a draw the match was
clenched on Board number three when
Matthew lson got the victory over
Alexander Katz and The Knockouts would
be knocked out team manager Alex maror
you see him there on the right was
elated to watch the results of the games
come in and see the archbishops move to
the next round so now we have the final
four of online team chess a big
accomplishment to be sure so in the
semi-final round next Wednesday the
archbishops will go up against the Miami
sharks led by Grandmaster Julio Basera
the Sharks will have the lower average
team rating however the Sharks also have
the archbishop's number the all-time
record between the two teams has Miami
leading
4-2 the semi-final round will be
broadcast live at St Louis Chess
club.org at 6:30 p.m. central Time on
Wednesday November
19th
a